ce que vous répondez à ceux qui disent
que le concours miss france et sexiste
parce que ça chaque année chaque année à
des polémiques ou autre concours alors
je sais que ça vous rend fou saint louis
je n'ai pas envie d'écouter parce que je
la trouve formidable et donc faire les
courses que vous disiez plein de
polémiques qui sont sortis le féminisme
etc moi je respecte la vie de chacun
parce que voilà chacun à chacun sa
définition et chacun voit les choses
comme il veut et ce qu'on peut être
féministe et fair miss france mais moi
je suis miss france et féministe ouais
bien sûr et j'avais aussi un mais c'est
vrai si oui j'ai quotidienne il ya
plusieurs définitions des féministes
exactement celle qu'on a envie de mettre
en avant ses coûts c'est quoi la vôtre
allons la mienne c'est j'ai envie de toi
pour moi une féministe quelqu'un qui
prend le pouvoir de sa vie qui décide de
faire ce qu'elle veut et on lui dit pas
ses lois moi quand je monte sur la scène
de penser que je suis aux côtés de situe
entre 18 et 24 ans qu'on prend le micro
devant des millions de téléspectateurs
conte défilent en maillot de bain je
veux dire je me sens plus femme que
jamais il prit féministe que jamais je
suis en train de montrer mes valeurs
devant des millions de français je veux
dire j'ai voté josé j'assume c'est ça me
semble plus messieurs fin je me sens
vraiment c'est important ce qu'a dit
c'est très bien répondu franchement et
aussi on a envie de prendre la parole en
maillot on est là c'est ce que je fais
tout le temps lâché en maillot se prend
la parole je chante jean carotide suis
comme ça je suis bien à quoi je suis
bien dans ma tête c'est une bien belle
josee j'ai exactement mail davis et le
défilé en maillot donc voilà c'est
qu'est ce que tu dis aux gens qui lisent
le défilé en maillot de bain c'est
insupportable c'est ici on peut pas
faire salle gilbert d'ajouter que vous
vous êtes pour oui ben moi je suis pour
parce que je trouve que c'est une une
galvanisation de la féminité je suis pas
je suis pas contre tous ceux qui disent
que c'est rétrograde que c'est une
humiliation au contraire je trouve que
c'est une exacerbation de la féminité
mais ce que je voulais vous demander
c'est que est-ce que vous
personnellement vous avez subi beaucoup
de critiques depuis le début de votre
parcours là dessus des amis à vous des
connaissances que vous êtes ne fait pas
ça c'est vouloir c'est maintenant un
gars ça va perso mon entourage personne
pour le coup et je vous rejoins de
mascouche pour moi miss france est pas
du tout regard normand latourelle
rendez vous assure franchement et puis
on ne peut pas dire que diane soit
regardable céréalière moderne
c'est delphine oui mais
le la chose que tu mets de côté ses de
ses liens de comprendre que miss france
est une année mais après c'est un
tremplin incroyable et ça ouvre des
carrières incroyable film je vienne
avait fait me de france à la base pour
me rencontrer
de son défi elle est où elle est là
alors une vie de rêve mondiale si elle
si elle le fait bien si elle est
travailleuse si elle est humble si si
elle aime son public elle pourra
travailler toute sa vie par rapport à au
tremplin de miss france et à sochaux
qu'elle va bâtir via d'ailleurs depuis
le titre
iag depuis le début syrie dit que vous
rêviez de rencontrer à ce que c'est vrai
a bien sûr cinéma oui mais bien sûr
comme tout comme tous les comme tous les
autres
tous les autres baladeurs dont vous
rêviez de rencontrer bernard montiel
également white autour de ce plateau
nonu sophie moment
c'est vrai la tension gaulle et à la
raison ce même faire le tour des
plateaux et tous actifs on attend son
passage de la miss france ça touche pas
à mon poste mais comme on attend son
passage au jt c'est vrai faut alors
justement vous vous êtes vous êtes en
plus c'est lui et aujourd'hui cette
année c'est quand même une année
importante parce qu'il va avoir un
nouveau président ont peut-être en
lançant le même président qui prime
emmanuel macron c'est important pour
vous parce que franchement ça va être ça
va jouer aussi peut-être que vous allez
être confrontés aux candidats c'est ce
que c est ça va être une élection
importante aussi une miss france cette
année vous allez être celle qui va
peut-être connaître le nouveau président
ou le le président voulait me parler
dans savez à chaque fois je me tourne
vers bernard montiel le président
sortant comme on dit asrar yb oui c'est
un beau bilan d'obama c'est important
pour l'argent pour bernard montiel
non mais c'est vrai c'est important pour
vous pas c'est vrai que je rencontrais
nouveau président après on mêle pas mis
ces politiques quand même donc il n'y
aura pas d'avis en tout cas sur la
politique ça c'est sûr